[Music]
and welcome back to Hannity tonight
reporting from Florida radio legend rush
limbaugh sat down with me earlier today
for an exclusive one-on-one interview
from his studio in Florida and we
started talking about the Republican
Party take a look you don't do a lot of
TV interviews you know I don't I don't
I'm totally satisfied with radio I'm I
want for nothing I love it so much but
this is special Kashan I tell you so the
reason America is still America is in
this room you mean the camera people and
all of us but you and me it's an honor
to do this it's great to be back on Fox
News and I'm actually grateful for the
opportunity here to be on the week
you're going back to 9 p.m. where you
should have been all the long so thank
you happy to be here
we appreciate it I want to start with
with tax cuts all the years you've
talked about it Kennedy Reagan how it
works what do you think of the tax plan
well you know it's it's good overall I
mean there's some things about it let's
look at the elimination of the deduction
state income tax you know who's going to
hate that California Illinois all these
blue states that's gonna cause a
shortfall for them those taxpayers are
not gonna like it and if you look at the
states with the highest state income tax
rates most of them are blue but here's
my basic problem with this
I keep hearing everybody say growth
growth but the top rate probably isn't
going to come down or much at all and
that's where the growth is those are the
people of hire those are the people own
small business those are the people that
spend we still give a tax system and a
way of explaining it that's rooted in
class envy we're gonna give the middle
class lower middle class upper middle
class and break but too rich we're gonna
soak them they don't need a tax break
they I've got enough and besides they
say we have to have a way to pay for
what do they pay for
why can't Washington do with less for
once we got growth from Reagan the whole
year I saw you talking about it last
night how top marginal rate over eight
years went 70 to 28% look what happened
why not do it again
the reason is everybody is afraid they
lose votes of the middle class
there's far more of them than there are
people in the upper bracket the top 10%
are paying 70 percent of all income
taxes and how can you say they're not
paying their fair share and why do we
want to punish them further if you
really want growth lower everybody's
taxes across the board and get out of
the way for all the revenues to be
coming he's gonna have a corporate tax
Trump wanted 15 it's gonna be 20
reconciliation kicks in so they say but
what's interesting is all right the
corporate taxes reduced through patreon
is good you're right New York California
New Jersey Illinois they don't get to
deduct I'm in New York it's 10% right
California is 13.5 percent exactly lower
rate they might have 39 to 35 but
they'll pay more gonna be paying more
and here's I've talked to some very
powerful people and I'm a powerful
influential member access to powerful
people and they're laying this all off
on the president this upper bracket no
movement and because they know when I
talk to them that I'm gonna be
interested in across the board everybody
because they're the ones talking growth
they're not saying we need to do this to
generate revenue they're saying we need
to do this to reboost the economy well
why are you gonna leave out the people
and hire why are you gonna be why don't
we use those people as role models
inspirations it's typical class warfare
but anyway the guy that I was song as
well don't talk to me the president
wants it's a president's insisting on
the president said that guys like him
don't need a tax break so they're laying
this all off on him when I hear we have
to find a way to pay for it that's
Washington establishment talk that's
democrat talk paying for tax cuts that's
right that this thing first day it's
presented is never going to have be how
it ends up if they get a get a vote on
it but no mr. stan there's some great
things in this personal exemption
doubles repatriation is good but the the
thing that bothers me is that we still
want to demonize and punish achievers I
was excoriated for saying I never got a
that I've worked in restaurants since I
was 12
right worked in construction for years
I was demonized for saying I never got a
job from a poor person right ever well
there see those that you're not supposed
to say those things you're not supposed
to say things that contradict the
narrative and the narrative in what it
looks is all about getting reelected
it's it's all about trying to claim that
they have things in common with the
middle class the downtrodden and so
forth that's why I don't think it's
really about growth it's about politics
and getting votes let's talk about the
Republican Party we saw what happened
with health care let's get you general
impressions on health care and I'm
convinced there's a pretty significant
percentage of Republicans in the Senate
they do not want this president to
succeed yeah I agree with you I think he
goes further than that
I don't think they expected to win I
think they like everybody thought Trump
was gonna lose in the biggest live I
think they thought that at 8 o'clock at
election night
they weren't preparing to govern they
haven't made any plans for it they have
become accustomed to being the quote
loyal opposition which means eventually
caving and gives the Democrats what they
want after putting up a good front seven
years going to repeal and replace
Obamacare but we can't do unless you
give us the house can't do it until the
Senate can't do it gave them all of that
you know the drill and you're right they
don't want to do it I don't it's I I
think that the voters come second it's
kind of like this NFL thing the owners
there have a a real conundrum there
little dilemma who do they choose they
choose loyalty with their players and
their customers that's a tough decision
well Republicans in the Senate and the
house who do they choose donors or
voters that ain't your choosing donors
the donors don't want major reform of it
and owners want amnesty the donors want
comprehensive immigration reform when it
comes to health care III you can tell
they'd for seven years they passed bills
with no problem you could tell they
didn't want to do it you could tell they
didn't want to repeal and replace it
they were just saying the words and they
all have their own individual reasons
but I think it's donors influencing Matt
more than voters will see but this is
embarrassment I mean there's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunities being
totally squandered we're never gonna
have this chance you actually said that
if they were smart and all they would do
is keep their promises they would govern
for generations this is the deal I
really believe that if for just three
months going forward or if they had them
three months in the past just three
months gut it up for three months and
work with Trump on his agenda on cutting
taxes seriously across the board
immigration reform the wall what have
you getting rid of Obamacare which it's
just it's it's an absolute crime what
has happened here and what that's gonna
mean it don't just just try for three
months make it look like there's unity
between the president of people his own
party and they would own Washington for
a generation mm-hmm that's a I I think
you're right
I'm looking at the Republican Party I
think Trump has a strong identity ran on
a platform sticks to it every speech
sounds like his campaign speech where's
the the brilliant ideas how many years
on radio have you talked about health
savings accounts health care
cooperatives we don't hear about that
how many times have we heard about the
wall I don't see them embracing strong
ideas and going and selling them which I
think they win on this I don't think
they're conservative I don't think they
ever have been I think I think they are
there isn't much conservatism in the
establishment there are Republicans and
Democrats but it's basically people who
are prone to think government
Washington's the center of the world
they'll give they'll give occasional
mentions of these things that you
mentioned these policies to placate
voters but going back to an original
question you have here
they don't want Trump to succeed with
his agenda they can't afford that I'm
not I'm not exaggerating here and I'm
not trying to say things that'll be a
soundbite that Fox replays the rest of
the day they don't want five days rush
to play a five they don't want they
can't afford for him to succeed with his
agenda they can't afford it the lids
blown the gig is over the joke is
revealed if an ounce
with no prior political in and fix
messes that people have been promised
would be fixed for 30 years how does
that make it look they can't allow that
to happen
[Music]